welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
were breaking down the Invisible Man
this is the first horror movie starring
John Cena
sorry icon and the film has a lot to
unpack from it the Invisible Man seemed
to give away the whole movie in its
trailer but when you watch it you'll see
there's a lot of things that it merely
teases and overall the film takes some
unexpected turns throughout this video
we're going to be giving off full
thoughts on the movie answering some of
the questions that you may have and
discussing what it's ending means there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to see it yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now if
you enjoyed the video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you subscribe
with notifications on to never miss an
episode
without the way thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into our
breakdown of the Invisible Man
[Applause]
there you are
The Invisible Man has been a character
that has lasted for centuries and for
good reason
created by HG Wells all the way back in
1897 the Invisible Man has left an
imprint on society due to its study of
human psychology and comments on what
one could do if no one else could see
them there have been several reboots
over the years but few have really left
their mark
that's where Blum house step in and from
the after film is by far one of the best
depictions ever put to screen The
Invisible Man
really recaptures the horror element of
the antagonist and appoints its
genuinely terrifying the film itself
follows Cecelia Cass who in the dead of
night manages to escape from her abusive
husband Adrian Adrian is a genius level
scientist that's accumulated a lot of
wealth
however he harbors a darker side to his
personality that comes with the power
Adrian has tormented Cecilia and pretty
much trapped her in a toxic relationship
that has led to the character's psyche
being severely fractured from the off
there are clear themes of isolation and
barricades around Cecilia whether it's
Adrian sleeping with his arm around her
all the huge walls that border the house
she's clearly been trapped Cecilia has
to fight tooth and nail to get out these
and yet Adrian is able to break through
them with these as we see when he
smashes his hand through the glass
window on a ride out of there after
breaking free from his grasp Adrian
apparently commits suicide
and leaves her a large portion of his
fortune this indicates the financial
control that abuses sometimes have over
their victims whilst it could seem like
she is finally free something isn't
right and Cecilia is slowly haunted by
something that she's unable to see she
also discovers at one point in the film
that she's pregnant with Adrian's child
and ultimately the movie is about him
going to great lengths to get her to
return to him with his prodigy now one
of the big questions I've seen on the
film is when exactly did this pregnancy
happen well there are two ways that it
could have which I'll give my opinion on
now Adrian is Tom implied could have
swapped out Cecilia's birth control the
other alternative is that he forced
himself upon her in the film as lip
service to her being only a month along
in the pregnancy and though we don't
know exactly when they last
together it is very muddy when this
happened personally I'm going with the
latter theory as I can see it more
fitting in with the character and the
personality that we see in possess in
the movie as mentioned earlier the
financial control is enforced with this
pregnancy and therefore it seems more
likely to me that the conception had a
sinister side to it you can decide for
yourself but I tend to sit more with the
twisted version either way it shows how
manipulative that Adrienne really is and
armed with some incredible technology
how dangerous he could be it's an
outstanding premise that not only makes
it one of the most unique adaptations of
the story ever but it also comments on
modern-day abuse and how it can often be
psychological as well as physical
Cecilia is clearly a broken woman and
had we not had the knowledge of the
title and premise before going in you
could definitely second-guess the
character's perception at certain points
and think that she could all just be
imagining it the men in the movie don't
really believe her and make excuses for
Adrienne and though James ultimately
turns out to be an ally it shows how
judgemental society can be gaslighting
is a big theme throughout the film and
whether this is a more supernatural
depiction of an abusive relationship or
not you can definitely take it and apply
elements of it to the real world horrors
are at their best when they operate like
this and it's no surprise that the
Invisible Man is receiving a lot of
acclaim for its execution and social
commentary it really shows how abusers
work and the patterns that they employ
to make sure that their victim really
has nowhere to turn the Invisible Man
systematically cuts off those around
Cecilia makes a question in herself and
in the end tries to force her back into
a relationship with him in an almost
Machiavellian manner it's clear that
Cecilia's relationship with men has been
forever damaged and it shows that abuse
can severely affect someone for the rest
of their life
even if they manage to escape a
situation that caused it it's truly an
inspired way to reinvent the Invisible
Man and I have to say early on this
quickly secured the spot of best horror
of the fme that isn't really that hard
right now especially with the boy - the
grudge and the turning but I think it
has set the bar very high in a way that
will be difficult for other entries
outside of a quiet place - to live up to
you after things begin to ramp up and it
becomes clear that Cecilia and those
around her are being hunted by someone a
twist comes in the form of who the
Invisible Man really is she discovers
that the Invisible Man has been living
in an attic and this reveal is enough to
send chills up your spine she slowly
sets out on a journey to get proof and
lots of the scenes of very tense in
atmospheric when revisiting Adrian's
home she discovers the invisibility
machine and realizes that the man who
has manipulated her has also discovered
a way to manipulate light now as for the
Invisible Man reveal initially most
including myself assumed it was Adrian
however we learn that it was apparently
Tom his brother who carried out all of
the attacks the invisible man killed
Cecilia's sister Emily and also framed
her for murder after she manages to
defeat him
we learn that Adrian has apparently been
a victim too locked away in his own
basement for weeks upon end most by it
and it seems like Adrian's ultimate
endgame has worked
however Cecilia doesn't buy it and she
wears a wire and agrees to have dinner
with him
whether here tom was carrying out most
of the crimes we don't know but
personally I think Adrian manipulated
Tom for this reveal and threw him under
the bus knowing that at some point it
would have to look like he was trapped
in his home so in my opinion Adrian was
pretty much behind it all of the time
as with most abusers he tries to suggest
a fresh start
whilst also refusing to admit that
there's been any wrongdoing Cecilia
insists that he tells the truth so that
he'll finally implicate himself and no
he doesn't out-and-out say it he
discusses how their lives together will
have a surprise which is a callback to
earlier in the film when he also used
the word to torment her it's a truly
chilling moment when you think you have
it all figured out but the movie
continues to throw curve balls as it
heads into its final scenes
Cecilia gets up and goes to the bedroom
and Adrian seems very smug in his
demeanor but something changes and
Adrian stands up and appears to slit his
own throat similar to the manner that
Emily was murdered perhaps the girl
finally got to him right well don't bet
on it
as we learn that it was actually Cecilia
behind it all using the invisible suit
that she hid earlier in the movie and
Adrian's own CCTV against him Adrian was
so comfortable in his control over
Cecilia that he was completely
blindsided by this move and his ego
really was his biggest downfall never
could he imagine that
one he believed was his slave could rise
up against him and take over but Cecilia
delights in doing this initially it
seemed as if Cecilia just wanted
Adrienne to confess but this move shows
that she is far more intelligent than
Adrienne gave her credit for and using
his own technology against him makes the
revenge even sweeter the ending for me
symbolizes that abuse victims can often
feel that they're invisible but they're
not and they do have a voice and the
ability to stand up to their abusers
though Cecilia has to go to incredible
lengths to do this in the process she
gains independence and with the
knowledge of all that she's gone through
she will avoid abusive relationships in
the future the movie also showcases how
abuse leads to further abuse violence
and revenge and elevates the horror
above most she calls the police and
tells them that Adrienne has killed
himself and gives the performance of a
lifetime to sell a story to the cops
that show up abuse victims often have to
pretend that something happened when it
didn't such as they fell down the stairs
and this ability to lie to those who
looked deeply at what's going on has
become a weapon in her arsenal she
leaves the house and goes off to start a
new life for herself with the invisible
suit which is the only thing that would
be able to prove that she was complicit
in Adrienne's death going forward there
have been people theorizing that there
will be a sequel but I think as a
standalone piece it works far better
than anything we could get potentially
showing what Cecilia could be doing in
the future now I have seen some people
saying that Adrienne could have been
innocent and that Cecilia could have
committed this murder mistakingly
however I think that the themes of the
film itself shut this down a lot as we
ourselves when saying this or relegated
to being the men that simply don't
believe Cecilia even though we saw the
things on screen play out the way that
they did it's a genius move and overall
it's a reason why the film is such a
well-made piece of work now before we
get into the review I just want to let
you know we're giving away a free copy
of the infinity Saga box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in when the chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the film in the
comment section below
but when it's gonna be chosen at random
on the 15th of March and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part as for my thoughts on the
film I'm sure you can guess I absolutely
loved it whether it was the pacing
subject matter or just the general turn
of events at the film tuck everything
worked for me here it's perfectly
grounded by Elizabeth musses performance
and she is quickly becoming an actor to
watch due to her abilities to paint out
a vulnerable person that slowly
overcomes - things are thrown at her not
only is this the best horror movie of
the air in my opinion it's one of the
best movies of the air and it's a solid
way to kick-start the new direction of
the dark universe
I can't wait to rewatch it and overall
the movie was a blast and it gets a nine
out of ten
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the Invisible Man and what
you took from the film comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of I'm not okay with this
which is gonna be linked at the end we
go over everything you need to know
about the Netflix show so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can also suggest video topics and
breakdowns you massively appreciate it
and it goes a long way to helping videos
like this get made you wanna come chat
to us after the show either follow us at
Definition YT or click the discord link
in the description below those are the
best ways to keep up to date with every
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe a
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]